hey my name is Rachel and I'm gonna show
you how to get plenty of protein without
meat or dairy I really wanted people to
be surprised because I think people
really only consider proteins to be like
chicken fish steak so this video was
really important to me and one I wanted
to make for a really long time because I
wanted to answer that question that
vegans and vegetarians have heard a
million times which is but how do you
get your protein I think one of the
breakfasts I chose that people might eat
all the time and not realize has as much
protein as it does is the oatmeal
because that's like such a common
breakfast and 3/4 a cup of oats is about
7 and 1/2 grams of protein and then if
you add in like peanut butter that's
obviously gonna give you a boost as well
I tried to choose a lot of dishes that
people are already familiar with the
ingredients people were maybe already
making like sweet potatoes and grain
bowls and veggie burgers lentil soup I
purposely did that because I wanted
people to go hey I eat that anyway it's
not this weird obscure ingredient I can
only get it like a health food store
it's stuff you're familiar with and you
see at the grocery store all the time so
anyone can do it so the butoh bowl is
also something that's pretty like common
nowadays and if you count the quinoa
which has a ton of protein and then you
add it to the chickpeas which beans and
legumes have tons of protein and kale
and leafy greens have a ton of protein
and then there's the tahini dressing
which has sesame seeds another form of
protein it just really adds up pretty
quickly and it's a lot more than you
might think it's gonna be I also think
the loaded sweet potato is like a super
quick and easy lunch that you might not
realize has just over 20 grams of
protein if you really like loaded up
with some beans and some corn and some
broccoli which has protein you know you
might not think of like broccoli is
having protein but it does and so to
leave
means people think of sweet potatoes as
being carbs but they also have protein
so I really wanted to break it down for
people to show them exactly how much
protein is in the foods that they're
probably already eating a lot of and
show them it's not as hard or as
intimidating as they might think it is
and that they're probably eating way
more protein than they think they are
[Music]
also the cashew mac and peas was one
that I was excited about because you
have the cashews which add protein to
the sauce you have the pasta itself
which has more protein than you might
realize
and then the peas were like a surprise
source of protein for me I was like oh I
didn't even think of peas so much as
having protein so this video took me a
really long time to produce because not
only did I have to pick and develop and
cook the nine different recipes but then
I had to break down the protein for
every single ingredient but it was worth
it because this was my most shared video
of all time and I am really proud of it
obviously you're gonna need to adjust
your portion sizes the amount calories
you eat in a day depending on your
height and your weight and your activity
level and you know even if you're not
totally vegan and don't want to be
totally vegan that is completely fine
but the whole point of making this video
was just to inform people that plants
have more protein than they might
realize
[Music]
you